What was life like for non-Muslims under
Muslim rule?
>> Well, so we Okay, let's first start off
with what Islam teaches because Islam is
very specific about life for
non-Muslims. If you're going to be a a
[laughter]
if you're going to be a non-Muslim, so
again, like I said earlier,
theoretically, according to Islamic law,
you have to be a person of the book to
be granted any measure of tolerance. All
right.
>> Monotheistic. You have to believe
there's one God.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And well by but
>> or what do they mean specifically
Christians and Jews?
>> No. Well, that's that's the question.
The term is which means literally the
people of scriptures or the book and the
idea it was more or less the Jews and
the Christians but then later on it sort
of became um it was extended to people
who weren't Jews and Christians and that
was because they got tired of the blood
bath. So for example when for five c for
five centuries I want to say between
let's say the year th00and to 1500
Muslims according to well doumented
historians uh historical sources and I'm
the historian I'm thinking of uh I know
his name but uh he's an ind Indian
historian and anyway he says that in
that five centuries um 80 million Musl
Hindus were slaughtered because they
weren't granted the option of becoming
them which Christians and Jews could you
could keep your religion. You just have
to pay extra tribute and you of course
have to be a secondass citizen which was
not in any way, shape or form any
>> dig into that. So you have to pay Jazia.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh don't know if I'm pronouncing that
correctly.
>> No. Yeah. Jiza.
>> Jiza. You I thought you laughed in my
face for the pronunciation. Um
>> No, it's just a funny word.
>> Uh so you have to pay Jizia and you uh
you are allowed and not allowed certain
things, right? So talk to us about what
that looks like.
>> Okay. So it goes back uh according to
Islamic teaching, remember the khalif
Omar?
>> Yeah.
>> The second khalif. So um apparently when
he historians aren't sure where, but the
Islamic tradition believes it's when
Jerusalem was conquered in 637 and he
came there. There's this big, you know,
narrative about how he came there and
whatnot, but supposedly he made a pact.
It's called in Arabic Omar or the the
pact of Omar with the Christians. And
they basically told them, "Here's what
you have to do in order for us to not
kill you," basically. And according to
this pack, things that they could not
do, they can't build churches. They
can't repair churches. They can't sing
out loud. They can't show a crucifix or
a Bible around Muslims. They certainly
can't try to proitize. They can't stand
in the way of their own relatives being
uh turning Muslim. Okay? And it's a it's
a number of lists. I actually translated
in one of my books. It's and it's called
the conditions or stipulations of Omar.
Some of them are if a Muslim wants your
seat, get up and give it to them. If a
Muslim is traveling and wants to enter
your house, you have to let him live
there. Okay? So, it's not stuff that you
necessarily want to enjoy. But what it
really coalesed around is it's still
evident till today. Okay? is you know
you're just you know it's it's I I guess
to give you a good analogy is kind of
think of uh you know how blacks were
treated in America and you know before
civil civil rights and uh and that which
is like kind of like who do you think
you are okay you know to even think
you're my equal that kind of mentality
is what prevailed in these Islamic
societies so if you're a Christian or a
Jew you better know your place and don't
complain and don't if someone if if they
abuse you or Muslims rise up and and
commit an injustice against you, the law
is not going to come on your side. That
continues till this very day. Even even
in, you know, the things about like
building churches, that's still very
evident in places like Egypt, you know,
where they it's so hard for them to get,
you know, it used to be actually you
need a presidential decree to build a
church in Egypt, okay? And uh now it's
supposedly become lenient, but a lot of
that people say it's just for show for
Western consumption. Um but in Egypt
constantly just this weekend I I covered
a story which has happened
countless times including going
centuries back which is basically some
sort of romantic leaison grew between a
Christian man in Egypt and a Muslim
woman. And so the Muslims after Friday
prayers rose up completely devastated
the Christian village or where the
Christians were living burned homes
attacked through rocks rioted screaming
Allah Akbar. And why? Well, actually,
because according to Islamic law, um, a
Muslim man can marry a Christian or a
Jew or person of the book, like I said,
but he has to hate her.
>> But, uh, a a non-Muslim cannot marry,
um, a Muslim woman. And the obvious
reason in the Islamic mentality is the
man's in charge. So, we cannot have an
infidel in charge of a Muslim. Okay? But
it's okay if the man's a Muslim and the
infidel, it's already a second class, so
it's a woman, you know, that's the
mentality. Um, so that's why they got
angry. But this story has happened
countless times in Egypt where they get
up and they engage in collective
punishment which the the conditions of
Omar which I was describing to you
actually um it says if one of you does
this then the pact is broken for all of
you. So it actually does promote
collective punishment of the dimm as
they're known and this like I said it
just happened this week. It happened
maybe two weeks before that because
there was a rumor of a church being
built also in Egypt and it goes way way
back. So my point is that it's actually
a written codified thing and it's become
absorbed in Islamic law and Islamic
Sharia, but it's also just part of the
society because it's it's a supremacist
idea. Okay, I'm better than you. You're
the dirty keer. You're the infidel.
You're the Christian. You're the Jew.
Whatever. So how dare you want equal
rights with me? That's the overarching
principle and it continues to manifest
itself with extreme regularity.